-Each player gets a turn
giving silent clues
to their teammate.
30 seconds on
the clock per turn.
We'll do four rounds
worth one point each.
The fifth round is
a Charades Showdown,
where both teams get
the same clue at the same time.
Jessica, why don't
you start us off tonight?
I'll sit there.
Team Bomer over here.
-Okay.
-Kelsea, yeah.
You guys go there.
-What number?
-Yeah.
Audience, want to help her out?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Three, I heard it!
Three, three.
-How come they just yell
"three" immediately.
Like, "Three!"
All right.
[ Laughter ]
We can do this, now.
Come on, Charades.
-Okay.
This is a good one.
-Okay, good. I love it.
I love a good one.
-Okay.
-Yep. Here you go.
-Ready?
-Uh-huh.
Song.
Oh, no. Five words.
First one -- Me, I, love...
Rock 'N' Roll!
[ Ringing ]
[ Band plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dude, come on!
-That was great.
-You feel that?
-I mean, come on.
-Can you feel it?
-That was good.
-That's how you do it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right, now you can go.
-Me?
-Yeah, you can go now.
-You want to go first?
-No, I want you to go first.
-All right.
-Phew! Come on.
That was good.
You're great at Charades!
There's plenty of time for that.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Pressure.
-5.
-Oh.
-[ Laughs ]
-Dang it.
-You're wishing you chose
the other one.
-It's all right.
-Okay.
-You like a challenge.
-All right, here we go.
-All right, ready?
[ Clears throat ]
-Song.
Four words.
First word.
Washing, record.
Popping out a cake.
Singing.
[ Laughter ]
Wait, are you joking?
You're spinning a record.
It's a baby. It's a child.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't do that to a child!
-Well, I was...
You're right.
Four words.
Fourth word.
Drinking.
Wine.
Sipping. Water.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Audience groans ]
-Is that it?
-Am I the worst, or was
that hard?
-No, that was hard.
-I don't understand.
What was it, 'cause it was great
whatever it was.
-It was "Genie in a Bottle"!
-Oh!
-I was Aladdin
rubbing the lamp.
But then, I was the genie
and I wanted to grant your wish!
-Now that you say it,
it makes sense!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I thought you were doing, like,
a "Sunshine of Your Life"
kind of thing.
-He was holding the lamp
like this.
-Just, wow.
I'm sorry. Okay.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Okay, okay.
All right.
-I'm right here with you.
-We got this, we got this.
-Give me an inside one.
Give me an inside joke.
-I'm giving you an inside clue
right now.
I'm giving you a clue.
-Got it.
-All right, done.
-Here we go.
Are you ready?
-Yes.
-Here we go.
-Movie.
Three words.
First word.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
A dance!
"Dances With Wolves."
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Ringing ]
[ Band plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Easy!
"Genie in a Bottle"!
♪ It's not unusual ♪
♪ To have love from anyone ♪
♪ A bada bada da ♪
♪ It's not unusual ♪
Oh!
[ Audience shouting ]
-I got 2.
-Kelsea?
-Come on, Kelsea.
[ Laughing ] Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay!
-The audience thinks...
-Sorry, Mom.
They think you can do it.
-All right.
-Movie.
Two words.
First word.
-Um...
-Show.
-"Genie in a Bottle."
-[ Laughing ] Exactly.
Out of a -- Pull it out.
Magician.
Magic.
Magic?
-Hmmm....
-Magician.
-Mm-hmm.
-Wizard.
-Hmm, hmm.
-Wizard?
Magician.
Okay, second, okay.
First word.
-Mm-hmm.
That was the -- right, correct.
Second -- two.
Um...
[ Buzzer ]
[ Audience groans ]
-I'm sorry.
-You do a little... and then...
-Just guess.
-Do that again?
[ Laughter ]
-"Magic Mike"!
-Yes, of course!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We need to give it to him!
We'll give you that!
[ Ringing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
First of all, first of all,
I don't know what strip club
you go to, where it's like...
[ Laughter ]
-But did you get the bunny?
-Like a very shy...
a very shy --
No, your "magic" was great.
But the "Mike" part --
Well, I don't know.
All right, here we go.
-I didn't know what to do.
-It was very shy and
very stripping something off.
All right, now!
[ Strong exhale ]
Here we go.
We're tied right now.
-Okay.
-So, now, Matt, you and I
give it to our partners.
-Oh, okay.
-And whoever gets this,
it's worth 80,000 points.
So that's how --
Yes, whoever wins this
wins the whole thing.
-Come on, baby.
Come on.
It's our time, baby.
-Okay, here we go.
-It's our time.
[ Audience shouting ]
Seven?
-Yeah, no, seven, of course.
They live seven.
Yep.
All right,
we share the same clue.
-Oh, hoo hoo hoo hoo!
-No, we share the clue!
-Oh, I got a good one.
-Ooh!
-Oh, yeah, baby!
-No, no, no! No, baby!
-Yeah.
-Okay, okay, okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-Ready?
-All right.
-Here we go.
-All right, you ready for this?
-Oh, yeah.
-One, two, three.
-Yelling!
-Four words.
-Eating!
Fire, blowing fire!
-Eye.
Oh, tear.
-Crying.
-To cry.
Crying.
-In a circle.
-Crying...
-"Cry Me A River"!
[ Ringing ]
[ Band plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh!
-You know him!
You know him!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Man, he is going to kill us!
Oh, my gosh!
-Am I going to get divorced?
[ Laughter ]
-That is "Cry Me A River."
It's a great song by some guy,
I can't remember who it is.
Oh, my gosh.
Our thanks to Jessica Biel!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But the champs are Matt Bomer
and Kelsea Ballerini!
[ Cheers and applause ]